bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 week end comme
tous les vendredis vous le savez nous
vous donnons quelques idées de sorties
alors au programme des expositions du
théâtre ou encore du sport avec les
rendez vous à ne pas rater ce week end
mais tout d'abord place à notre première
invitée
alors pour celles et ceux qui aiment se
déhancher voici une activité qui va qui
devrait vous plaire une zumba fio est
organisée ce samedi 14 mars au club le
village de montigny-le-bretonneux pour
en parler avec nous kadi baradji bonjour
mesure alors vous êtes le coach sportive
et c'est vous qui organisez cet
événement est ce que vous nous dites
vous en dire un peu plus oui bien sûr
alors en fait moi j'ai organise
l'événement avec un prestataire qui
s'appelle face events moi je suis prof
de zumba est donc l'idée c'est d'amener
c'est-à-dire de de faire un événement
plus
poussé le la zumba vers le fluo amener
enfin rendre l'événement un peu plus
attrayant plus plus convivial est
beaucoup plus amusant est alors d'accord
au niveau de la tenue du coup ça se
passe comment les gens doivent venir
avec un accessoire flux obligatoirement
alors en fait au niveau de la tenue donc
l'accessoire pas forcément fait il faut
s'habiller en en tenue qui ressort à la
lumière en fait parce que c'est géré en
réalité là ce qui se passe c'est qu'on
est dans le noir et que ce sont des
lumières ultraviolets qui permettent en
fait de ressortir les couleurs ce qui
fait qu'il faut que les gens ils sont
habillés en blanc ou en couleur qui
ressort bien comme le rose fluo le jaune
fluo un petit peu sur les images sons
qui sont diffusés et alors la soirée se
déroule en deux temps dont il ya d'abord
une séance à 18h30 avec un cocktail donc
à 15 euros et la deuxième séance qu'il
démarre à 20h30 avec l'europe a cette
fois ci qui fournit à 25 euros c'est
bien ça exactement en fait là la
séquence à 18h30 en réalité il ya trente
minutes de maquillage quand les gens
arrivent ils sont maquillés sur place
donc il ya une maquilleuse une
maquilleuse maquilleuse qui est là pour
ça et donc qu'il aima qui en fait en
fluo pour que pour qu'on voit alors
leurs visages
étant donné qu'ils vont être face aux
profs
pour bien les voir en fête et voir les
mouvements et surtout être vu en fait
parce que ils vont être plusieurs les
uns à côtés des votes on est dans le
noir il faut se voir donc ils seront
maquillés et donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut aussi avoir une tenue adéquate et
c'est vous qui a animé la séance du coup
si vous laissera vous la professeure
donc moi je serai professeurs et pour le
coup on a des invités surprises qui vont
aussi se joindre à nous qui vont être
prof aussi et donc on va être plusieurs
professeurs a animé sa fait c'est la
nouveauté de cet événement et est-ce que
c'est accessible à tous même à ceux qui
ne font pas de sport d'habitude qui
n'ont jamais cette zone bah oui tout à
fait c'est vraiment accessible à tous
par exemple la première session elle est
ouverte aux enfants donc c'est moi je
suis aussi prof de zumba pour enfants du
coup la première l et c'est vraiment
tout public adulte enfant la seconde
comme c'est une heure et demie en c'est
déconseillé pour les enfants ou alors
ils font vraiment pas tout les 1h30 mais
sinon c'est vraiment accessible à tous
les sportifs ceux qui ont envie de
sortir c'est vraiment là pour l'occasion
juste un moment pour se défouler pour se
défouler s'amuser d'accord alors la
zumba aujourd'hui on connaît ça que
celle dont se développe depuis plusieurs
années ce que vous pouvez redéfinir un
petit parce que c'est avec vos mots
alors comment moi j'ai défini la zumba
c'est
pour moi la zumba c'est vraiment une
grosse fête
c'est un moment où on s'amuse
tout en brûlant des calories on brûle
vraiment beaucoup de calories et et sur
des musiques qui sont bien rythmé de la
musique latine
il ya des rythmes africains
vraiment toutes les musiques qui bouge
permettent en fait de faire de la zumba
et c'est ça qui est excellent en fait et
pourquoi à votre avis justement cette
danse prend un essor ces dernières
années qu est-ce qui qu'est ce qui
attire finalement les gens
moi je dirais que ce qui attire la zone
ce qui attire les gens à la zumba ça va
ça va beaucoup beaucoup dépendent du
prof en fait les profs il faut vraiment
qu'ils que les gens se sentent bien dans
leur cour qu que ce soit convivial que
ce soit qu'on s'éclate et consentent pas
en fait qu'on soit
vraiment content en ressortant de son
cours de sept des foulées de cette
dépense est et c'est je pense que c'est
ça qui fait qu'un à la zumba je vois
personne tirer la tronche
on a passé notre semaine une autre
journée avec nos soucis quotidiens et
puis quand on vient à la zumba on oublie
vraiment tout et on se devait de latence
vie de la tête et je pense que ça c'est
très important alors qu'a dit baradji
vous êtes coach sportive dans l'est dans
les yvelines qu'est ce que vous proposez
concrètement ce que vous faites
plusieurs choses d'être coach à domicile
on voit aussi des cours de zumba ce que
vous en dire un petit peu plus sur vos
active alors en fait moi je fais
beaucoup de choses vraiment beaucoup de
choses je suis bas effectivement je suis
coach sportive à domicile je fais aussi
prof de pf prof de tennis pour les
enfants je fais beaucoup de choses déjà
tous voila j'ai enfin je vis du sport et
je fais du sport tout le temps c'est une
grande passion pour moi et et et très
tôt en fait j'ai eu envie de partager
cette passion et du coup c'est ce que je
fais au quotidien en tant que coach
sportive à domicile ben je me rends chez
les gens
je suis à l'écouté de leurs besoins de
ce qu'ils ont envie de faire et en fait
l'avantagé d'un coach sportif
contrairement à la salle de sport en
fait c'est qu'il va vraiment être là
pour nous si un jour j'arrive etc la
cliente est fatigué par exemple la
séance elle va être adapté à l si on va
dans une salle de sport on va dans un
cours collectif si on est fatigué ou si
on s'est fait mal
si on n'a pas une bonne journée la
séance ne sera pas adapté à nous le
cours et les préparer pour tout le monde
et c'est vraiment ça la différence avec
un coach sportif en fait ça évite aussi
les des motivations d'un ami
effectivement une phase le coach est
envahie qu'il a tonné on ne peut pas
d'accord et alors comment ça se passe si
on peut prendre des cours avec vous vous
proposer un diagnostic au début comment
ça se passe alors quand on m'appelle on
a un rendez-vous diagnostic au cours
duquel moi je checke un peu je posais
des questions sur les antécédents sur la
vie
globalement de la personne si elle a
déjà été sportive si elle à pratiquer
d'autres sports ou si elle ne l'a pas
fait du tout s'il ya eu des grossesses
il faut il faut vraiment
pas vraiment s'intéresser à la personne
pour pouvoir répondre au mieux à 100 à
ses attentes à ses besoins et à ses
objectifs il est je vous exercez que
dans les yvelines ou comment ça se passe
vous restez sur 50 ans ni ville ou plus
largement dans le département même même
ailleurs ça dépend de la demande si
c'est vraiment trop loin je vais pas y
aller dès fois ça va pas être
intéressante mais sinon en général mais
je travaille essentiellement sur 50 ans
mais j'ai aussi des séances sur paris je
peux me déplacer ça ça me dérange pas
tout dépend de mon emploi du temps très
bien et vous proposer des cours de zumba
où ça beaucoup alors je suis basé à la
grande île à voisins le bretonneux ont
fait d'accord
je travaille est une association qui
s'appelle bouger voisins qu'on a quand
moi je fais partie aussi et du coup
c'est une association avec laquelle je
travaille depuis maintenant un an très
bien mais si on veut rentrer vous
rencontrez en tout cas rendez vous donc
ce week-end le samedi 14 mars à partir
de 18h30 donc au clip au club le village
de montigny-le-bretonneux l'occasion de
se dépenser un peu dans la bonne humeur
merci caddie baradji avec est revenu sur
notre plateau quant à nous on reste dans
l'univers de la danse monsieur et madame
rêve le dernier spectacle mis en scène
par marie claude pietragalla est
proposée ce samedi 14 mars à 20h30 à la
ferme du manet de montigny-le-bretonneux
un spectacle à la croisée de l'art et de
la science voici un extrait
allez on passe aux expositions du moment
le club de l'image en boîte présente
jusqu'au 5 avril à la galerie du
mousseau à elancourt une exposition de
photos sur le thème des différences
sortie des cadres les clichés nous
transporte et nous questionnent quant à
l' approche subjective des photographes
aurélia de bissy et patrick jacques de
dixmude
un travail collectif sur le thème des
différences c'est l'objectif que se sont
donnés les membres du club de photo
d'elancourt l'image en boîte 18 mois de
travail auront été nécessaires aux 25
participants pour exposer une grande
diversité de photos contemporaines le
numérique et les moyens d'impression
actuelle en notamment permis de
privilégier une scénographie originale
on est sorti des cadres on a on a fait
de grands formats on a aussi utilisé des
des techniques de collage de
présentation qui nous permettent de
montrer une exposition qui est varié
dans sa scénographie et c'est ça aussi
qui nous a intéressés chaque thème est
et cohérent dans sa présentation et et
on passe de un peu comme on tourne les
pages d'un livre on passe de deux d'une
série à une autre avec une autre
présentation et c'est ça je pense qu'ils
donnent de la la vie à cette expo
singularité portrait architecture ou
encore séquence temporelle plusieurs
sous thématique sont exploités pour
présenter les différences sylvain
salmond a choisi une approche sociale
sujet pour lequel il a une certaine
sensibilité ce que j'ai aimé présenter
ici c'est le chemin parcouru entre le
l'avancé justicière ont toujours
tendance à dire retient le temps passe
très vite et c'était hier pourtant et il
est actuellement c'est une des raisons
pour laquelle si vous regardez les
photos vous ne voyez pas les visages il
n'y a pas de nostalgie sur les photos
j'ai voulu que le regard se porte sur
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire le les mains
bien sûr des personnes âgées et puis la
photo qu'il présentait une photo d'eux
mêmes ou les mêmes lorsqu'ils étaient
jeunes et donc ça puisse amener plus
avoir le chemin fait le chemin parcouru
de la vie qui est belle parce qu'en fait
elle est grande et longue et plus on a
des rides sur les mains plus le chemin
est long et ça veut dire qu'on a on a
profité de sa vie au moins est le lien
entre les mains
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire un stage qui
m'était permis dont pas la société de
qui est derrière farcissez assistait
donc il travaille beaucoup sur
l'intégration dû handicap dans le monde
du travail à l'occasion de ce stage là
je me suis dit mais bon sang de bonsoir
là nous sommes en train de de reparler
de l'évolution de le des rythmes
scolaires de vouloir intégrer une
deuxième langue en 5 dès la 5e je me dis
mais pourquoi n'a t breton palais le
langage des mains dans la dans la
formation scolaire la différence de la
langue des langues est un quelqu'un du
nord de la planète au dessus de la
planète pourrait rencontrer et
communiquer avec qu'à l'autre uniquement
par la langue des signes d'où le titre
de la série mes mains langue universelle
parce qu'effectivement cette fois faire
tomber les différences de la longue et
ça s'intègre également dans le
dans le tome de l'exposition une
exposition surprenante et riche de sens
à découvrir jusqu'au 5 avril
exposition toujours elle a démarré cette
semaine se poursuit jusqu'en avril la
mer la mezzanine de l'hôtel de ville de
lyon cours accueillent le travail du
grand reporter pierre-yves ginet il
photographie les résistances de femmes
dans le monde actuel entre 1998 et 2006
il s'est rendu dans 17 pays pour ses
clichés un beau travail à découvrir on
passe ensuite à l'actualité sportive du
week end
michael et demi d'euros notre
journaliste sportif nous a rejoint en
plateau bonjour bonjour je m alors il ya
de quoi faire ce week end oui il y aura
beaucoup de matches ce week-end on entre
dans la dernière ligne droite des
championnats chaque point est important
dans la course aux premières places ou
au maintien en rugby il y aura un choc
ce dimanche en promotion d'honneur saint
quentin en yvelines deuxième du
classement se déplace chez le leader
massif central la victoire est
indispensable pour les saint quentinois
ils doivent s'imposer pour conserver la
deuxième place du championnat ils sont
talonnés par moment ci par clichy qui
sont respectivement à deux et à quatre
points de saint quentin en yvelines au
classement
toujours en rugby montigny-le-bretonneux
reçoit savini ce dimanche à 15 heures au
stade roger couderc en championnat de
première série normalement il ne devrait
pas y avoir de souci pour les inhumant
temps les hommes de cyril mûri et
réalise une très bonne saison avec une
deuxième place au classement et
seulement trois défaites au compteur ils
sont également intraitable à domicile de
plus ils pourront une nouvelle fois
compter sur leur ailier anglais le
virevoltant william price c'est simple
britannique est à une moyenne d'un essai
par match
oui il y aura du handball ce samedi chez
les garçons le chesnay-versailles se
déplace ce samedi sur le terrain de
neuilly en thelle pour le compte de la
16e journée de nationale 3 les
chesnaysiens sont actuellement la
deuxième place du classement avec 36
points il vise la première place du
championnat dès ce week-end le leader
lille et à seulement un petit point des
joueurs yvelinois en basket masculin le
fc trappes saint quentin en yvelines ne
reçoivent a tenté de se sauver dès ce
week-end les hommes de mustapha el
hafidi affronte ce samedi à 20 heures au
gymnase paul mallet l'éveil sportif
d'ormes
un duel qui paraît déséquilibrée sur le
papier trap est actuellement la septième
place du classement et or mais juste au
dessus à la 6e place la clé du match
pour trappe sur une nouvelle fois la
défense les trappistes sont réputés pour
avoir l'une des défenses les plus
solides du championnat et en football
américain dont les templiers d'elancourt
joue ce week end ils vont essayer de se
reprendre c'est ça les templiers
d'elancourt présentés comme les favoris
de ce championnat lites n'y arrive pas
pour l'instant après trois journées ils
n'ont toujours pas enregistré la moindre
victoire après un nul pour la première
journée du championnat contre les
cougars ils ont enchaîné deux défaites
contre les molosses si les black
panthers conséquence les templiers
pointe à l'avant dernière place du
championnat le match contre les flash de
la courneuve est programmée à
l'extérieur ce samedi à 19h ce ne sera
pas simple pour les templiers qui
doivent impérativement l'emporter et
après le football américain dont il y
aura également du soccer ce week end
c'est à dire du football mais avec les
pièces et sa du football avec les pieds
donc magny les hameaux club de deuxième
division senior var sauvage où ce
week-end les hommes de farid gainey sont
actuellement la première place du
classement avec cinq points d'avancé sur
le second le chesnay ce dimanche à 15
heures il reçoit les derniers du
classement le pecq la rencontre paraît
déséquilibrée sur le papier si vous
voulez assister à ce rendez-vous le
match est programmé ce dimanche à 15
heures au stade de la pointe du chemin
cours et alors ce week-end ce sera
également un moment de recueillement
pour le sport français c'est ça les
instances sportives veulent rendre
hommage aux huit français dont florence
arthaud camille muffat et alexis vastine
et aux deux pilotes argentins décède en
argentine dans un accident d'hélicoptère
les la fédération française de football
a lancé qu'une minute de silence serait
respectée sur tous les terrains de
l'hexagone que ce soit au niveau du
national régional ou départemental la
fédération française de basket a
également annoncé qu'une minute de
silence respectée sur tous les parquets
français voilà yolaine pour tous les
rendez vous sportifs du week-end dans le
département merci beaucoup michael à
bientôt on continue cette édition quant
à nous avec du théâtre
la compagnie calvero était en résidence
à la maurice de trappes pour les
dernières répétitions de la carte du
temps trois visions du moyen-orient une
pièce jouée ce week end le samedi 14
mars à 20h30 sofia programme et william
elles ont rencontré le metteur en scène
musicale nous étions dans la famille en
fait les autos c'était un peu comme des
juifs des musulmans et des chrétiens
tout ouïe dire que des fois il a réussi
un petit pot les halles avec un petit
peu de sang
irak palestine israël voilà les
ingrédients de la carte du temps trois
visions du moyen-orient cette pièce
réunit des personnages démunis par un
conflit qui les dépasse avec humour
émotion et humanisme les israéliens les
politiciens se détestent comme il se
doit enfin comme il se doit comme ils le
font malheureusement et malgré cet
antagonisme malgré cet adverbe adversité
ils vont être obligés de ils vont être
amenés à faire quelque chose ensemble
ces deux peuples qui se déchire sont
très très proches et il ya des choses
que je ne comprends pas en fait je ne
comprends pas je ne je ne comprends pas
pourquoi il ya cette nécessité de se
fracasser de se taper de se détruire
pour pouvoir
vivre codage voilà et ce projet l'âme
apporte des réponses et ça c'est génial
une pièce écrite par naomi wallace une
dramaturge américaine inscrits au
répertoire de la comédie française
ce qui est très beau dans l'écriture
naomi wallace séquelles grâce à ces
histoires qu'elle invente elle nous
permet d'imaginer nos spectateurs que ce
monde ci n'est pas le seul en tout cas
moi c'est un texte que j'ai cherché
pendant longtemps
parce que je suis né en algérie et un
pour moi ce qui se passe au moyen-orient
c'est une deuxième blessure après un
succès au festival d'avignon en 2013 la
compagnie calvero sera sur la scène de
la merise de trappes les 12 et 14 mars
pour rencontrer aussi son public
j'aimerais qu'il se dise je les
imaginais pas comme ça les autres
l'autre que ce couac soi que je
diaboliser soi que je vis des alizés
aisée
et peut-être se dire peut-être que c'est
possible peut-être que ce monde ci n'est
pas le seul
et voici encore quelques idées de
sorties pour vous ce week end et on
commence à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines le cirque zavatta
douchez est de passage ce week end un
show coloré pour petits et grands dure
deux heures ce spectacle avec des
artistes internationaux
rendez vous ce samedi à 16 heures et
dimanche à 15h pensez à réserver à
voisins le bretonneux ce samedi 14 mars
également ne ratez pas la séance de
dédicaces à la librairie lettres voisine
l'occasion de rencontrer thomas gilbert
le dessinateur de bjorn le morphir et en
avant première vous pourrez y découvrir
le tome 4 de ses aventures et qui
sortira le 18 mars à voisins le
bretonneux toujours la magie revient ce
week end l'association les 78 tours vous
présente sapristi leur tout nouveau
spectacle
rendez vous samedi 14 mars à 15 heures
pour les enfants et à 20h30 pour les
petits et les grands tout cela à la
salle de la tour de l'espace culturel
decauville
l on termine cette édition avec le coup
de coeur d'un professionnel du cinéma
celui de l'udc beaucamp dû signer cette
d'elancourt
alors deux coups de coeur cette semaine
aussi des fêtes le premier c'est une
comédie policière ce pionnat ge
davanture qui s'appelle kingspan avec
l'acteur oscarisé colin firth qui nous
donne là une interprétation tout à fait
sublime en agent secret on va dire rater
qu'on vient chercher malgré lui et qui
va résoudre malgré lui encore une fois
tout un tas d'affaires alors c'est un
film qui représente un genre assez peu
enfin je trouve représentés dans les
salles de cinéma c'est le film
politiquement incorrect originale qui
part un peu dans tous les sens mais qui
a très bien fait l'on sait vraiment à
découvrir ces savoureux c'est assez
manière que l'on juge ana vous savez ce
que ça veut dire
alors je vais éclairer votre lanterne
on va traîner là toute la journée où est
ce qu'on va se battre
franchement navré j'avais besoin de
décompresser et puis le deuxième coup de
coeur c'est une opération qu'on monte
régulièrement avec service culture de la
ville d'elancourt qui s'appelle cinéart
et donc on aura donc une séance dimanche
à 18h du chef-d'oeuvre du film on va
dire maintenant de patrimoine
d'antonioni qui s'appelle blow up voilà
et ce film sera suivie d'une conférence
de gabriel du héros qui parlera à la
fois du travail de cinéaste d'anthony
mais aussi du travail des photographes
en particulier voilà et ça c'est
dimanche à 18 heures
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis bobo week end à tous